on passe au panel avec michel david et
jonathan trudeau ce soir bonsoir à vous
deux bonsoir bonsoir on va parler de la
sixième vague parce que elle fait parler
elle aussi on regarde les chiffres on
voit vraiment la tendance elle est forte
elle monte vite le taux de positivité
maintenant est rendue quand même à 18%
les chiffres les nouveaux cas ça c'est
seulement les chiffres avec les tests
pcr mais c'est quand même la barre des
3000 cas qui a été franchie pourtant ça
ne semble pas beaucoup troublé le
ministre de la santé qui recense dubé
qui ne veut pas remettre en place
d'autres mesures sanitaires on va
l'écouter
rien n'empêche d'être beaucoup plus
prudent puis je le dirai partout au
québec mais particulièrement en région
qui ont pas eu cet effet là alors c'est
des grandes lignes oui on est préoccupés
mais en même temps c'était prévu puis je
demande aux gens de continuer à se
protéger mais aucune raison pour le
moment aucune raison pour le moment de
changer la stratégie qu on up parce que
les gens doivent apprendre à vivre avec
le virus continuer à se protéger
non michel je commence avec vous appelle
à la prudence on le comprend bien ici
mais vraiment basé sur une
responsabilité individuelle avec cette
fameuse phrase il faut apprendre à vivre
avec le virus france vraiment plus
j'entends plus je me demande qu'est ce
que les gens comprennent à cette phrase
ben on le voit je pense que les gens ont
compris que ben on va finalement le
danger était passé et que l'on peut
faire à peu près ce qu'on veut on le
voit là moi je suis allée ya pas
longtemps la bande à aulas man ou
personnes portaient des masques et j'ai
l'impression que les gens ont
l'impression à tort que c'est fini et le
gouvernement est le premier responsable
de ça maintenant le monsieur dubé assure
qu'il n'est pas question de prendre de
nouvelles mesures je comprends que
politiquement là ça devient extrêmement
délicat pour le gouvernement alors
retomber le dada de quelques formes de
de restriction à laver ou à l' approche
des élections ce serait ce serait
dramatique on le voit déjà là il ya un
mécontentement qui s'est sédimenter je
dirais et il fait que la caq les
sondages le récent qui ne montre qu'il
ya une chute peut-être pas aussi
important que j'ai des réserves sur ce
sondage là mais il reste politiquement
ce serait dramatique pour pour le
gouvernement mais si on en arrive au
point où les hospitalisations commença à
augmenter le coût de 100 200 par jour je
pense le gouvernement doit de voir un
moment donné prendre ses responsabilités
parce que en effet des risques du côté
des risques à bouger et de ramener des
mesures des risques aussi à ne pas
bouger jonathan un peu plus tôt choisi
une entrevue avec docteur cesser le
tremblay qu'ont eu moult fois elle en
entrevue pendant ses années de trop vide
qui est musulman n'est pas une personne
très inquiète mais qu'il a dit ça augure
mal ce qui s'en vient devant nous parce
que c'est extrêmement contagieux et elle
elle en appelle au gouvernement là à
prendre des mesures à remettre à
redonner de l'axé aussi aux tests pcr et
toutes ces choses là ce que vous trouvez
aussi que le gouvernement prend un
risque en ne bout j'en fais actuellement
il prend un risque menace qu'il faut
savoir comme dans toute bonne gestion de
risque que ce soit dans une entreprise
privée ou au gouvernement sait quel est
notre tolérance du risque est ce que le
risque il est acceptable moi quand je
parle avec des gens du gouvernement
également de la santé publique il ya des
facteurs qui sont pris en compte il ya
le fait que le bo2 semble être moins
virulents dont on n'a qu'à regarder
autour de nous connaît tous des gens qui
ont contracté la copie de 19 au cours
des derniers jours dernières semaines on
y en a moins qui sont affectés plus
gravement jeu du poker en europe mais la
proportion semble être un moindre on dit
également qu on regarde ce qui s'est
passé ailleurs dans le monde avec cette
sixième vague qui oui semble forte
montée rapide mais un plateau ci qui
vient assez rapidement et qui réduit
assez rapidement et on me dit avec le
printemps plus qui est à nos portes on
va ouvrir les fenêtres on va respirer
sans oublier que on nous dit qu'il ya
plus de 3 millions de québécois qui ont
eu la corvée de 19 heures au cours des
derniers mois donc cette espèce de
principe d'immunité collective qui peut
commencer à s'installer mais n'est-ce
qu'un risque politique pour le
gouvernement par exemple a ramené des
mesures sanitaires évidemment personne
ne vous dirais le contraire mais de là à
penser que le gouvernement à ce que
suffisamment irresponsable pour l'amour
des évidences devant lui qu'il met la
population en danger et que pour des
raisons électoralistes il ne le ferait
pas j'en doute sincèrement ça lui ferait
pas plaisir mais rappelons nous quand
même que le québec est la seule province
qui garde encore le masque est
obligatoire dans l'espace public ont été
les plus sévères pendant longtemps je
pense qu'on est rendu à une étape où on
doit augmenter de niveau de tolérance et
c'est ce qu'on est à près de tester en
ce moment pour mac est d'ailleurs que
les partis d'opposition pose pas le
gouvernement a ramené des mesures par
contre ceux qui disent ça nous prend des
données on a besoin de paramétrer cette
montée de nouvelles vagues on écoute
certains représentants de partis
d'opposition
si on n'a pas accès aux tests pcr on
risque de rater
le bon médicament au bon moment pour
certains patients on n'a pas les
indicateurs adéquats pour voir l'ampleur
de de la vague actuelle et ça moi j'en
appelle au gouvernement à rétablir des
systèmes de dépistage que ce soit par
les eaux usées ou vous partez ce spécial
c'est pas un peu étonnant justement le
ministre dubé le cas nous parle par
exemple de son travail le réformer le
monde de la santé dit moi je veut mesuré
je veux des données chez un homme de
mesure vous me connaissez mais quand on
lui parle de sixième vague on a
l'impression que le il se prive de
données alors qu'il pourrait aller en
chercher en rendant accessible et spcr à
tout le monde où il est élargi à tout le
moins le fameux paramétrage là où on
vérifie les eaux usées on le fait en
ontario on n'a cessé de le faire au
québec et pourtant ça serait un outil
qui pourrait bien pratique jonathan ce
que ça vous étonne c'est comme sur de
contradictions paradoxe chez nice dubé
sur les thèses par rapport aux wolves et
effectivement je comprends pas pourquoi
ça semble être difficile de ramener
cette pratique lui qui était fort utile
la même certains sont ont été surpris
d'apprendre à quel point ça peut être
utile le dal y étudient ce genre de
données là par contre sur les tests pcr
faut comprendre que m'a donné le virus
se propage à une rapidité telle que ça
devient possible c'est pas étranger à ce
qu'on a vécu dans la cinquième banque et
c'est à dire lorsque le gouvernement ont
reconnu qu'il n'était plus en mesure de
donner des données fiables mais qu'on
comprenait qu'il y avait certaines
tendances mais je pense que c'est c'est
la même chose il ya des données qu'on
doit surveiller je pense à la
propagation au niveau du milieu
hospitalier les hospitalisations sont
une donnée qui membres ce non plus le
nombre d'hospitalisations qui est en
haut en osmose doit aussi accepter qu'on
peut pas non plus à vendre une
mobilisation aussi importante que celle
qu'on a eu pendant près de 24 mois au
niveau du personnel qui vient des
diverses milieu pour pour citer cela on
doit aussi accepter que m'a donnée y
aura une probable propagation je répète
la même chose je dis on dédie
collectivement qu'il fallait apprendre à
vivre avec le virus belle inconnue fait
un peu aussi partie de cet apprentissage
vous êtes à l'aise avec ça vous michel
parent dont vous êtes à l'aise avec son
avec cette approche-là de fonctionner
avec moins de données sans les
indicateurs par exemple qu'elle pourrait
nous donner les eaux usées tout ça non
pour ce que des u12 et je pense que je
vois pas pourquoi on s'en passerait pour
ce qui est du pcr moi j'ai l'impression
que la population l'embarquent rapport
on a pris l'habitude des tests rapides
maintenant les gens s'en satisfont
beaucoup et il reste qu'à écouter on a
tous autour de nous des gens qui un jour
après jour contacter la coved et on voit
bien que c'est pas
c'est dramatique que ça dans la plupart
des cas alors je pense que la tolérance
au risque a augmenté dans la mesure où
les gens considèrent qu'il est moins
important qu'il fallait d'avant mais
pour ce qui est des hospitalisations il
reste que le québec et on le voit de
loin la province où il ya la plus forte
augmentation et c'est aussi l'endroit où
le système de santé est le plus fragile
ses pas l'ont aidé débordé au moment où
on était autour de 2000 il y avait des
cris d alarme partout on n'est pas si
loin que ça c'est au rythme où là où ça
progresse alors je pense
qu'effectivement le gouvernement va voir
si ça se poursuit la tendance poursuit
un choix extrêmement difficile à faire
parce que c'est dans mes filles et duda
méfier donne est changée et seulement je
me permets
les doigts pour que ça arrive pas j'en
attends oui à la lumière de ce que je
viens dire je vais quand même spécifié
nos à nos téléspectateurs je ne compte
joint qui travaille dans le milieu de la
santé qui comme des dizaines de milliers
de personnes a été durement éprouvée par
les deux dernières années donc comprenez
bien que je suis loin d'être insensible
aux risques que ça peut représenter
je pense qu'on es ou s'y rendent une
approche qui doit être ciblée on doit
absolument garder l'oeil sur le nombre
d'hospitalisations sur la capacité de
notre système à faire face à ces
hospitalisations là mais en même temps
on peut être plus ciblés je pense par
exemple ou à la quatrième dose aux
personnes qui sont plus vulnérables
la protection justement des personnes
vulnérables et moi je pense que un
élément qui va s'avérer incontournable
mais ça peut déplaire aviez déjà c'est
que le port du masque le retrait du port
du masque obligatoire qui était prévu
pour le 15 avril nous avons entendu je
l'aï interviewé moi même le docteur
boileau aujourd'hui je pense ça me
semble assez évident qu'on va reporter
ce matin là on est en plein coeur d'une
sixième vague sur soi même le plus
contradictoire de dire ben on retire le
masque on nous dicte une bonne mesure
barrière encore j'ai l'impression qu'on
devra de roaillan durer encore quelques
semaines passées il est pauvre elle
confirmé en disant c'est sûr mais il
ouvre la porte on l'entend dans les
entrevues il ouvre la porte là dessus je
n'attends tous les deux vous avez fait
référence aux sondages
au risque politique aussi pour la cac
évidemment on n'entend plus on en laisse
dans les sondages on comprend bien mais
quand même un gosse sur 8 qui était
intéressant aujourd'hui qui ressortait
un point qui disait que 26% des gens qui
ont voté cac serait prêt maintenant à
voter conservateur et jusqu'à maintenant
parce conservateur sa ligne c'est
l'opposition à toute mesure sanitaire et
on voit que même dans les autres partis
y ait des petits glissements des
intentions de vote soit il ya vraiment
un effet d'attraction est ce que c'est
juste de la colère justement de la
fatigue pandémique où les gens veulent
plus entendre parler de la pandémie
veulent plus entendre parler des mesures
sanitaires michel ou est ce que quelque
chose donc pour expliquer ça non je
pense que effectivement monsieur duhaime
a beaucoup profité
de la fatigue center mais même au moment
où vraiment on pensait que c'était
passablement fini le parti conservateur
a continué sa progression alors je pense
qu'il ya réussi à fédérer les mécontents
de tous ordres qui sont pas
nécessairement
liés ou aux mesures senneterre ça ça
peut être le système de santé en général
ça peut être la crise du logement parce
que c'est bien étonnant de voir des gens
qui je pense près de 10% de jacquet le
parti conservateur avoir cherché et qui
viennent de québec soldats évidemment le
gros de son potentiel ce sont les
électeurs cas qui nous ont que le lien
beaucoup plus facile à faire mais ceci
étant dit je regarde ce sondage la
dengue ne suis que vous mentionnez et je
peux pas m'empêcher de trouver que ce
sondage là qui a été effectuée seulement
une semaine après celui de léger
marketing arm différence là on parle de
la caq à 33% alors que les gillham était
à 41 pour ça j'ai beaucoup de difficulté
à croire que l'espace d'une semaine il
ya pu y avoir un tel glissement way
ce sens qu'on dira on prend soin quand
même avec un grain de sel n'est ce pas
ceci dit il ya quand même une élection
partielle qui sent bien qu'ils s'en
vient vite marie-victorin vote par
anticipation c'est dimanche et lundi
donc dans quelques jours jonathan est ce
que ça va être un indicateur justement
le stade hier rendre concret un peu
peut-être qu'on voit dans les sondages
qu'est ce que vous en pensez jusqu'à
quel point ça va être un révélateur
à baisser sauf qu'ils ont un test et on
le voit qu'ils ont un certain
mécontentement sur le terrain dans
marie-victorin bon et le parti québécois
qui a commandé un sondage qui l'ont
rendue publique qui démontre qu'ils
auraient une avance de huit points
parlant de petites réserves je vais m'en
garde et une parce que je pense qu'on
est prêt d'une égalité jeu c'est
quelqu'un que des chiffres qui eux les
maîtres légèrement en avance clairement
moi je me réfère davantage aux derniers
léger qui démontrait que les deux
parties étaient nez à nez mais dans les
faits quand on regarde la popularité de
la cac un peu partout au québec on
serait porté à croire que ce serait
facile pour pour eux dans marie victorin
or il ya deux facteurs qui semble qui
semble jouer en faveur du pq est
peut-être en défaveur de la cac c'est
que le parti québécois un candidat qu
une très très bonne notoriété qui vient
peut-être faire surperformer le parti
québécois qui franchement on arrache
sincèrement solidement partout ailleurs
au québec pierre nantel qui est un
ancien député qui est apprécié qui est
une figure reconnue donc lui le fait
performer le parti québécois et alain
weisz bella candidat de la cac semble
avons de la difficulté à s'imposer
madame doris m'ont donc ce que ses
parents pour effet de tirer un peu vers
le baume une chose est certaine c'est
que parties voudront interpréter cela
comme étant un signal en vue de la
prochaine élection si la quête
l'échappée se serait vu comme étant le
un symbole du mécontentement et pour
ceux du parti québécois ben ali l'ugtt
ne pas exagérer mais l'autre
pratiquement pour leur survie pour
démontrer qu'ils sont capables encore de
s'imposer donc c'est une lutte à finir
le bien malin celui qui peut prédire
comment ça va se terminer le 11 avril
prochain moréac sont michel bah écoutez
je suis quand même un peu surpris de
ce n'est un éloge comprend que monsieur
nantel est beaucoup plus connu que tous
les autres candidats en fait dans marie
victorin mais il reste que le parti
québécois est traîné vers le bord depuis
depuis des mois et là il faudra voir je
pense que la participation va être
déterminante laquelle organisation va
réussir à faire sortir son vote il y en
aura probablement pas beaucoup la cie si
on atteint les demies noir la dernière
partiel le site est d'ailleurs de 30 ou
40 pour ça
alors ça devient beaucoup une bataille
d'organisation un moment donné parce que
je pas certain que les gens vont se
précipiter vers les urnes oui hélas
jusqu'à quel point ça va être révélateur
pour le parti conservateur parce que
l'on n'est pas dans les régions de
québec l'on est à longueuil où il ça
c'est fondamental
ils gagneront pas mais si le parti
conservateur fait 15
seize pour ça
dans un comté où c'est vraiment pas sa
clientèle on peut penser que dans des
régions comme la région qui avec la
grande région et veulent le réduire ils
vont vraiment performer bon alors ça va
être intéressant à suivre de toute façon
messieurs c'est déjà terminé alors on va
parler de covin probablement plus
souvent qu'on aurait bien voulu non
seulement prête mais c'est la vie
jonathan michel merci beaucoup au revoir
votre choix pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit